se escribe la siguiente expresión como
un producto con exponentes positivos
posteriormente evalúa la expresión
cuando x es igual a 2 y nos dan x a la
menos tres por cinco a la menos dos por
equis cuadrada y lo que hay que darse
cuenta aquí es que si tienes algo
elevado a un exponente negativo eso es
exactamente igual a 1 sobre la misma
base elevada a la versión positiva del
exponente así x a la menos a es igual a
1 sobre x a la así que aplicando este
conocimiento aquí tenemos que x a la
menos 3 es igual a 1 sobre x cúbica por
5 a la menos 2 que es igual a 1 sobre 5
al cuadrado x
x cuadrada y que tenemos entonces en el
numerador tenemos uno por uno por equis
cuadrada así es que esto es igual a
equis cuadrada y en el denominador
tenemos x cúbica por 5 al cuadrado 5 al
cuadrado es igual a 25 aquí podemos
suponer que esto es implícitamente x
cuadrada sobre 1 entonces tenemos 25 x x
cúbica por 1 esto es igual a 25 x x
cúbica y aquí podemos simplificar esta
expresión porque tanto el numerador como
el denominador son divisibles entre x
cuadrada x cuadrada entre x cuadrado es
igual a 1 y x cúbica entre x cuadrada es
simplemente igual a x y aquí podríamos
utilizar otras propiedades de los
exponentes pues x al cuadrado entre x al
cubo es igual a x2 menos 3 esto es igual
a x a la menos 1 y x a la menos 1 es
igual a 1 entre x así es que aquí
tenemos uno entre x de cualquier manera
que la hagas mientras sea una manera
válida vas a obtener el mismo resultado
al simplificado obtuvimos entonces uno
sobre
x ahora nos pide evaluar cuando x es
igual a 2 cuando x es igual a 2 esto es
igual a 2 y aquí tenemos 1 sobre 25 por
2 que es igual a 1 sobre 50 y hemos
concluido que escribimos la expresión
con un producto con exponentes positivos
fue lo que hicimos aquí todos los
exponentes son positivos y le evaluamos
para obtener 1 sobre 50